und damit herzlich Willkommen zu Porsche
Trader Folge 6 die Folge in der ich alle
offenen Fragen beantworten werde konnten
wir weitere goldbälle verkaufen und mehr
Gewinn erzielen wie sieht's aus mit den
50 € von onlogist die uns am letzten Tag
für die letzte Fahrt verwehrt wurden ich
stehe jetzt um die Website der meiner
Meinung nach besten Idee die wir bisher
in diesem Projekt hatten wie steht's um
den Poster Shop und vor allem aber um
welchen Porsche geht es hier eigentlich
die ganze Zeit und worauf arbeiten wir
eigentlich hin
ja und um euch standesgemäß über den
Verkauf der letzten Golfbälle
aufzuklären erstmal das hier sind die
letzten beiden Golfbälle die wir
überhaupt davon haben also wirklich die
allerletzten zwei bisher hatten wir
734 € und 72 Cent eingenommen da ist
aber noch einiges dazu gekommen
[Musik]
nein
731 € und 48 Cent durch Einzelverkäufe
also irgendwelche Mix Pakete die wir
verkauft haben was völlig geisteskrank
ist und dazu noch mal wovon hier dieser
Ball übrigens auch noch einer ist
ungereinigt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
200 Euro für zweieinhalbtausend Bälle in
Balk ungereinigt nonnen-markenbälle ich
hätte 2500 goldbälle in verschiedenen
Qualitäten und mit von allen Marken
abzugeben ich hätte jetzt an sowas wie
20 Cent pro Ball gedacht
aktuell
[Musik]
geht nicht auf irgendwelche Golfplätze
und das Digger [__] euch an alle die
die irgendwas klauen und scheiß damit
machen und das ergibt insgesamt diesen
Betrag was völlig geisteskrank ist würde
ich mir jetzt einfach nur irgendwie den
Porsche arbeiten wollen für dich einfach
weitermachen mit Golfball Verkäufen aber
wir hatten ja noch ein paar andere Ideen
Video Nummer zwei onlogist das Video wo
ich mich mit Abstand am meisten für
[__] habe nachts im Auto gepennt habe
von A nach B kommen musste und so weiter
es hat Spaß gemacht aber war auch mit
Abstand das Video wo wir am wenigsten
Gewinn Potential hatten am Ende sind wir
mit 199 € und 47 Cent da rausgegangen
weil uns ja der letzte Auftrag mit 50 €
oder 55 € verwert wurde ist kein Problem
sie werden dafür bezahlt ich habe gesagt
Schuhe alles dafür das Geld wieder zu
bekommen was ist dabei rausgekommen es
gibt keine Möglichkeit für mich anders
Geld zu kommen onlogist hat aber das
Video mitbekommen und hat mir
freundlicherweise ein Paket geschickt
ein schöner Trost aber ein schönerer
Trost werden die 55 € gewesen Paket
bekommen von Logistik ich frage mich ob
da meine 55 € drin sind ansonsten bin
ich nämlich nicht
geil geil
von dir und cool dass du online das
Video mega geil als kleines Danke Schön
gruß aus dem Norden wir haben Gerichte
gehört dass du Champagner magst außerdem
nur für den Fall dass es nicht für einen
neuen Porsche rechts schicken wir dir
einen Manuel einen etwas günstigeren
Porsche an dem man auch selber schrauben
kann und damit haben sie den Nagel
ziemlich gut auf den Kopf getroffen
vielen dank onlogist vielen vielen Dank
aber ich hätte gerne sehr sehr gerne
noch die 55 €, weil das hier bringt mich
im Projekt nicht weiter das ist eine
sehr nette Geste und ich werde mir den
Champagner absolut reinstellen aber das
Geld
als unser sorgenkind-video meiner
Meinung nach die beste Idee die wir in
diesem Projekt hatten also klar die
anderen Sachen waren auch witzig und
alles wunderbar aber das wäre die Idee
gewesen von der ich gedacht hätte Alter
wir machen richten das einmal ein und
dann passiv Kohle jeden Tag jeden Monat
durch den Verkauf von der AI generierten
Stockfotos im Endeffekt wir haben das
programmiert mit Hilfe von Leon wir
haben uns auf 70 30 geeinigt und was ist
passiert in dem Moment wo das Video
online kam wurden wir überall gesperrt
wenn ich bei den stockzeiten aber bei so
ziemlich allen ais bei wir irgendwie den
Namen von unseren Accounts drin gelassen
haben und so weiter und es wurde uns von
den Machern der is verboten besonders
von mit John problematisch daran wir
können keine neuen Fotos hochladen
problematisch daran und neue Fotos
gibt's kein Geld wir hatten nur
begrenzte Fotos haben diese hochgeladen
und das einzige Geld was er damit
verdient haben war ein 5 €
Willkommensbonus für die ersten 25 Fotos
die wir auf wirestock hochgeladen haben
problematisch daran dieser Betrag wird
nur ausgezahlt sobald man 30 Euro
insgesamt verdient hat insgesamt liegen
also 5 € gelockt auf Wirecard die
bekommen wir nicht raus 0 Euro Umsatz 0
€ gewinnen können nichts machen uns ist
es verboten und somit ist die beste Idee
in der Praxis nicht umsetzbar und wir
können nichts machen richtige scheiße
und ja ich bin Hacker
und ihr fragt euch mit recht wie ich bei
diesem ständigen hin und her in dem
Projekt Geld rein Geld raus verschiedene
Projekte parallel den Überblick über
meine Finanzen behalte die Antwort ist
ganz einfach die Partner des heutigen
Videos Finanzen finanzguru ist dabei
dein digitaler finanzassistent der alle
deine Einnahmen und Ausgaben auch über
verschiedene Konten hinweg trackt und
dabei ist es egal ob Girokonto Sparkonto
Aktiendepot oder sogar Paypal und das
beste an der Sache die App ist komplett
kostenlos ihr seht also was reinkommt
und viel wichtiger ihr seht was rausgeht
weißt du z.B wie viele verschiedene Abos
du gerade parallel laufen hast und ob du
sie tatsächlich nutzt die App erkennt
durch regelmäßige Konto Bewegungen wo
irgendwelche Verträge am laufen sind und
gibt euch die Möglichkeit diese Verträge
rechtlicher zu kündigen und Ausgaben zu
sparen die App ist auf Basis künstliche
Intelligenz aufgebaut und lernt anhand
eures Einnahmen und Ausgabeverhalten
euch vernünftigen Überblick über eure
Finanzen und vor allem eure Potential
dazugeben vielleicht zeigt euer Konto
1000 € an finanzgur weiß aber das in der
nächsten Woche die Miete und der
Handyvertrag noch abgehen deswegen euch
eigentlich real nur 450 Euro bleiben das
ist ziemlich wichtig zum Planen und zum
Sparen damit ihr einfach nicht mehr Geld
ausgebt als ihr real habt für den ersten
Link in der Videobeschreibung und mit
dem Code Dave erhaltet ihr finanzguru
Plus für ganze drei Monate komplett
kostenlos und habe damit mehr Analysen
smarte budgetvorschläge und bekommt
Einsicht in zukünftige Buchung also
ladet euch die kostenlose App runter
registriert euch verknüpft eure Konten
tragt den Code Dave für drei Monate
kostenlos finanzguru plus ein und erlang
perfekten Überblick über eure Finanzen
vielen Dank an finanzberuf fürs möglich
machen und euch viel Spaß weiter mit dem
Video und zu guter Letzt kommen wir zu
unserem aktuellen Baby den Poster Shop
ich bin gestern bis 5 Uhr nachts wach
geblieben um meinen tiktok als Manager
einzurichten um Werbung zu schneiden
Werbung zu Tage hätten heute morgen
jetzt um 13 Uhr sind die Sachen online
gegangen und wir haben mit 1,78 € Kosten
direkt einen Verkauf gemacht wir haben
einen Verkaufspreis von 31,90 € Kosten
bei dem Artikel von 13,52 € und - die
1,78 € die wir an Werbung ausgegeben
haben immer noch 16 € und 60 Cent
gewinnen das ist
sommerhammer geil und genau so soll das
funktionieren wenn wir das jetzt
irgendwie so Erwachen können dann wäre
das geisteskrank und allgemein läuft der
Shop ziemlich gut denn auch der original
content hat performt um nicht zu sagen
dass der original content besser lief
als die Werbung und zwar deutlich besser
denn so günstig wie ich gerade eben
dachte dass die Werbung sei pro Verkauf
ist sie bei weitem nicht geblieben und
hätte uns fast das Genick gebrochen dazu
aber gleich mehr mit original content
konnten wir 149 000 Videoaufrufe
generieren 22.000 Profil Aufrufe 10.000
likes 1256 Kommentare die Videos wurden
750 mal geteilt und wir konnten knapp
2300 Follower plus machen was richtig
richtig stark ist erstmal aber noch
weiter zum Shop ich habe weiter und
weiter und weiter optimiert ich habe die
Kommentare gelesen was alles nicht
erlaubt ist habe diese Sachen
rausgenommen mit dauerhaftem sale und so
weiter und habe weitere Sachen angepasst
gehen wir also zum Beispiel in die
Shopping Card also gucken was wir uns
jetzt gerade in den Warenkorb gelegt
haben dann gibt es Anreize mehr zu
kaufen jemand tut ein Poster für 31 €
rein und mir wird angezeigt die fehlen
noch 7 € und 10 Cent für kostenlosen
Versand dann werden hier unten Poster
angezeigt die am ehesten zu dem Poster
passen was die Person schon im Warenkorb
hat wir tun einen Kendrick Lamar Poster
dazu und hier steht Versandkosten
gespart nur noch 14 € und 20 Cent für
10% Rabatt für ein weiteres Poster hinzu
dann steht Versandkosten und 10% gespart
und was wir sofort in den Analytics
sehen konnten war dass es tatsächlich
gefruchtet hat der durchschnittliche
Verkaufspreis in unserem Shop ist nach
oben gegangen und wir konnten
probestellung mehr verkaufen was
hammergeil ist auf der anderen Seite gab
es kleinere Problemchen manche Produkte
waren falsch Preis und haben mir zu
günstig verkauft so günstig verkauft
dass wir Minus gemacht haben dann waren
manche Sachen nicht im Shop eingebunden
die wir aber auf tiktok beworben haben
also wir haben jeden Fehler gemacht den
man als neuer E-Commerce King
Deutschland so machen kann und die haben
auch bezahlt und zwar mit Geld genauso
wieder Fehler mit der Werbung und jetzt
wird es richtig Banane in dem Moment wo
ich am tag eins gesehen habe wie günstig
ich für 1 Euro 86 hier einen Verkauf
gemacht habe habe ich gedacht wisst ihr
was ich hau mehr Kohle da rein desto
mehr Kohle ich da reinhauen desto mehr
Verkäufe mache ich und das ist genau der
Fehler den jeder Idiot macht der denkt
der hätte jetzt Social Media Werbung
hier für sich entdeckt was habe ich
getan
411 € und 42 Cent in Werbung gebuttert
und damit hier Poster in unserem Shop
verkauft vier Stück das ist unheimlich
schlechter also probestellung die über
die App kam überhaupt 100 € ausgegeben
und die ganzen restlichen Bestellungen
also alle 31 anderen Bestellung kamen
über original content und ich habe es
laufen lassen habe es nicht vernünftig
beobachtet und das hat uns fast das
Genick gebrochen insgesamt haben wir
1423 € in den ersten paar Tagen mit dem
Shop umgesetzt worauf ich unheimlich
stolz bin das Ding ist es ist Print und
das ist teuer und so weiter er hat
nämlich Gesamtkosten von 1
150 Euro für die print on demand Sachen
mit Versand mit Druck mit Rahmen und so
weiter was einem Gewinn von 367 Euro
machen würde hätten wir nicht 411 Euro
für die Werbung ausgegeben das bedeutet
stand jetzt sind wir im Minus und zwar
genauso viel das ist richtiger Müll
komplett mein eigener Fehler aber wir
wissen das System funktioniert und wir
werden es weitermachen das heißt mehr
Design mehr tiktoks machen die Werbung
besser schalten vielleicht holen wir uns
von irgendwem Hilfe dazu und dann damit
reich werden so bringt die gesamte
Arbeit natürlich nicht aber so ehrlich
muss ich sagen jetzt aber erstmal zur
größten und wichtigsten Frage für
welchen Porsche machen wir das hier
eigentlich angekommen im Paradies um
euch besser erklären zu können welchen
Porsche ich möchte und warum ich ihn
möchte und im Prinzip steht hier alles
was es gibt angefangen beim Macan dem
kleinsten kleinsten und günstigsten Auto
von Porsche super toller Wagen aber
nicht ganz das was ich suche der größere
Bruder der Cayenne deutlich Kopfhörer
deutlich größer Langstrecke entspanntes
Reisen hoch sitzen top-auto aber auch
nicht ganz das was ich suche Panamera
absolutes Traumauto aber für dieses
Projekt auch nicht ganz das richtige
Teig an der quasi elektrische Bruder
Wunder wunderschönes Auto aber ihr seht
vielleicht im Hintergrund ich habe schon
den elektrischen und für dieses Projekt
nicht ganz das was ich suche und ihr
merkt schon es bleibt nicht mehr viel
übrig 718 also Boxster oder Cayman oder
die Königsklasse 9 11 und in dieser
Königsklasse geht es von Standard
Carrera über einen GTS bis hin zur
absoluten Top-Klasse GT3 und vor allem
aber GT3 RS und klar könnte ich mir
einfach so ein Auto aussuchen wäre es
mit Sicherheit der neue GT3 oder so ein
992 GTS geworden ich mache das alles
aber nicht nur für mich sondern auch für
euch und deswegen wird es keinen neuen
Elfer sondern eins der vergessene
Modelle das hier nicht mal auf dem Hof
steht ein Porsche 944 und das mit gutem
Grund aus Porsche Trader heraus
entstehen nämlich zwei neue Serien die
es in sich haben einmal eine Porsche
Umbau Serie beteilig werde ich den
kompletten auf und Umbau dieses Autos
begleiten das bedeutet bauen wirklich
alles komplett um von vorne bis hinten
denn das Auto soll einen anderen Zweck
erfüllen als das wofür es eigentlich
gedacht haben dafür brauche ich Eure
Mithilfe ich möchte nämlich dass jemand
von euch das Auto gestaltet also die
Folie vom Auto gestaltet Links zu allen
Dateien wo ihr sie runterladen könnt und
mir eure Designs dann auch wieder
hochladen findet ihr in der
Videobeschreibung das wird ein mega
Projekt denn der Porsche 944 wird
Offroad Rally Dakar ins Beirat um danach
und damit kommen wir zu Serie 2 mehrere
tausend Kilometer durch komplett Europa
mein Begleiter für eine mehrtägige Rally
zu sein die bedokumäßig auch hier auf
diesem Kanal begleiten wir müssen im
Auto schlafen Kochen Leben und
verschiedene Challenges jeden Tag mit
dem Auto bewältigen und dafür eignet
sich dieser Porsche perfekt er ist
damals nämlich im Kooperation von VW und
Porsche gemeinsam entwickelt worden was
ist mir erlaubt selber kleinere
Reparaturarbeiten auf dieser Rally
vornehmen zu können was ich mir bei egal
welchem Modell nicht zugemutet hätte er
wird höher er wird breiter er wird
lauter er bekommt Dachgepäckträger und
vieles mehr behalten das also beim
Design im Hinterkopf vielen Dank fürs
zusehen vielen Dank für die
Unterstützung mit den Designs ich freue
mich auf zwei weitere Serien zu Porsche
auf diesem Kanal